israel
yeah you're back yes
how are you i'm all right
you're still around what's what's been
going on with you tell me give us an
update of
where your life has been since since the
last time we saw each other um
like as far as like how back
well since since the beginning of the
year when we did that third video
with with uh
your your
with what was his name um fly fly yeah
where's fly today um as far as i know
he's still in jail for the murder and
conspiracy
yeah so you guys were on the run for a
while right um yeah
well him
you were going with him from state to
state yeah
so he was
he's not been convicted he's just being
held for a murder uh-huh yeah well it's
like him and like nine other people
right
oh yeah so they murdered
some
he was a [ __ ]
and they murdered some bloods but they
also murdered an innocent
yeah a person as well bystander yeah
so he's in jail for that
yeah
pretty deep
yeah
and uh and what have you been doing
since since
um well we no longer talk like i don't
have communication with him at all
um
not his family or anything like that
um so i've just been kind of back on my
own so
like every now and then i'll still go
out to fig or like
um
hollywood or you know like just anywhere
i could think of to like make a couple
couple hundred if that i saw you on
figaro with a red was it a sun umbrella
yeah
yeah and um
besides that like instead of like
you know like paying for rooms every day
because that gets like out of hand i i
was able to find like a track a truck
bed camper so like a trailer
and so i've been like cleaning that out
fixing that up
and just staying in there me and the
kids so you're with the kids now
yeah for real this time yeah
i know there have been some
some uh
some lies going on in the past with you
and me but
um i think
you know the the the general consensus
on you changed drastically after that
third video where everyone started
seeing you as a hustler and a con artist
but the way i see it
you've been on the streets since what
since you were 12 right yeah a little
bit before that yeah so
these kind of
skills that you've developed to survive
are pretty much all you've known since
you were young
so you can't expect someone to just
magically
change their whole
way of living
as quickly as maybe i was even expecting
it
you know one of the most interesting
comments on your videos
i think it was on the third one was i
think it probably came from a social
worker
some viewer made a comment that it takes
a woman an average of seven attempts to
break away from an abusive partner
and this was maybe your first chance at
doing that when i was helping you out
so
i thought that was very interesting and
i think what's required in these kind of
cases whether it's with a drug addiction
or whether
it's getting somebody away from that
that kind of a relationship or getting
away from sex work it takes a lot of
patience and perseverance and
effort and ultimately money and i guess
on the bottom level it's love that's
required
to let someone make a change a serious
change like this in their lives
tell me where you're at mentally where
you'd like to
see your life going from here you're 23
still yeah um mentally like um like
since i've just like left the drugs
alone and everything and like been
focused on just me and the kids like
it's been
a lot better um
it's still hard because you know
sometimes i do find myself back out on
fig in other places
so that's still kind of hard because
that's something that i don't wish to
still be doing right
um so it's still kind of like a struggle
and emotionally is it tough for you um
yeah it's got to be discouraging yeah
right
and the streets are tough i mean that
that's a tough neighborhood you're
hanging out in
yeah
definitely girls are getting murdered
down there
are you still hanging with your your
gang friends
um no like i've
just like completely cut ties like you
know i've changed my number about okay
three four maybe five times right so
like nobody has my number i don't have
social media anymore god know like a lot
of the stuff i was getting caught up in
like as far as with them was through
social media and i just
i don't wish to be a part of it anymore
do you have anyone in your friends or
family do you have anybody other than
your boys
so it's just you and your boys who are
both very young are they in school yet
um they go to like a christian school
so it's not like an actual school but
are they a school are they have school
age yet
um jezreel yeah
like he's he should be
like kindergarten
kindergarten right
so where do you where do you see your
life going now what are you hoping for
um
[Music]
like i don't know i know i've been like
thinking a lot like i did start the
little like short films on youtube and
stuff but like maybe like pursuing that
more
yeah i mean with with 14 million views
on your first video i think there's
probably a lot of people that are
interested in your story yeah you know
there's been some twists and turns to it
but
you know your story is still very
interesting you know you're
you came from a terrible you you never
really had parents right no
and you've been working
you've been a sex worker since 12 i
think 13 yeah however
your life is a movie already
but you're having a good time with your
raising your boys yeah they're doing
well yeah
their birthdays this month so it was in
the it like it's at the end of the month
so june 29th and june 30th
but because i'm like so caught up doing
everything else i didn't know if i would
have time to do it actually on their
birthday so i just did it like a head
like way ahead
like pretty much at the beginning and
their their father is out of the picture
he's in prison right yeah he's in prison
for like the rest of his life
what have you learned from all of this
from everything you and i have been
through even
um
like i know i could say like as far as
like even like with your help and stuff
like that like you know like kind of
don't bite the hand that feeds you you
know or like um
like you know not everybody's out to
hurt you there is still good people that
just genuinely want to help and see best
for you
yeah see i'm not angry at you i i
understand that where you came from
where you where you come from
you're not used to somebody some white
knight coming in and saving the day like
this
you're probably suspicious of that right
from the get-go you just see me as an
opportunity to get some money
and that's what you and
fly probably
saw
and you you took advantage of that which
is what you guys
do
i think i'm guessing but
but maybe it'll take several attempts
more for you to figure out that maybe
people will help you out
or maybe you learn maybe you learn
quickly maybe social media
taught you that lesson quickly learn
quickly yeah yeah maybe you
you're seven seven attempts into it
already who knows
do you have any regrets in your life
you're only 23 but i mean
what
what regrets would you have
um probably like still being back and
forth in the street
um
like the whole situation that happened
between you and fly
and just like getting my head so caught
up and wrapped around in him that i
wasn't
really focused on what i needed to be
doing which was
leaving a lot of the bull crap alone
yeah well i'm good at forgiving and
forgetting so
we'll see where it goes from here but uh
i'm glad you were able to have the
courage to come back and
show your face here
you guys have done that in several
circumstances that
took a lot of courage i think so
i'm glad you came back and uh maybe
we'll do more updates and see where you
and the boys are going from here and uh
i wish you lots of luck thank you all
right is ryan thank you very much all
right thank you
you